il a mis le parfum d'art maman ça se
sent ça ce sens
là je n'aime pas simple quand ce renard
commence à faire le ménage et à à
brosser les trois poils qu'il a sur le
crâne c'est qu'il se prépare quelque
chose de mauvais
les nappes
point par point que tu entends tu
pourras tu me dire quel mauvais coup tu
prépares un médecin te regarde un pack
commandement enfin tu as vite chez moi
puis des ça ne te regarde quand même pas
tout mais j'ai quand même le droit de
savoir ce qui se passe sous nos propres
toits bon allez si tu veux je vais
inviter juni à venir prendre le thé avec
moi c'était une très bonne initiative à
hewitt je suis bien content que tu m'as
prouve mais malheureusement complètement
irréalisable
complètement quoi
irréalisable c'est à dire que tu ne
pourras pas le frein et pourquoi pas sûr
parce quand monsieur j'ai moi-même
rendez vous avec julie dans 5 minutes au
jardin c'est ce qu'on va voir avancer
c'est déjà tout vu oui et nous allons
même chanter notre chanson je voudrais
bien
casé mirkazemi tu ne vas pas commencer à
me casser les oreilles avec ta chanson
j'ai compris je vais voir des amis qui
au moins eux après simon pas long c'est
ça voudrait bien savoir comment
pour faire court
il est parti vite i télé france
téléphoner faut j'appelle jury
allons allons je lis oui c'est moi un
mois canal et en allons voyons oui
voudrais-tu venir prendre le thé avec
moi
quoi tu ne peux vraiment pas au rendez
vous avec casimir
tiens justement casimir est là et il
voudrait plus viennent ici
ok je te passe à huy rend bien sûr ne ne
quitte pas
je veux y passe casimir salon je suis
refait à moins que
alors je lis
je lis
allonge unis ne quitte pas je te passe
casimir
allons julie note ne quitte pas à ça
vient c'est moi c'est moi
pour atout venir ici très bien passez
par le petit bois j'estimerai d'aller au
devant de toi merci à tout à l'heure
pourvu que ça marche
enfin casimir passe toujours par le
sentier des lapins donc ils ne se
rencontreront pas et je vais décrocher
téléphone comme ça il ne nous dérangera
pas et là maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à
attendre
je voudrais bien ça à voir comment il
faut faire pour devenir sage par un
drame
je ne comprends pas julie m'a dit
qu'elle ne bougerai pas d'ici de toute
la journée elle m'a donné rendez vous il
ya déjà cinq minutes que je l'attends
julie
julie je suis là casimir tu l'as tu ne
t'appelles par julie que je sache non
non kazimi on est comme julie n'est pas
là si je ne t'avais pas répondu tu
aurais pu l'appeler encore comme ça
pendant un moment neuf ans et demi où
étaient alors
les chez toi quasi mais elle tâtonne je
ne comprends pas nous avions rendez vous
ici même écoute casimir vous vous serez
certainement mal compris téléphone lui
ah ça c'est une idée aux liens mais
enfin
c'est occupé à
je rappellerai un peu plus tard ça se
raccroche
je suis encore un petit gueuleton
peut-être non mais si léonard juste
parfait comme ça c'était délicieux
je suis maladroit je vis je suis et où
là chaque fois que vient prendre le thé
je suis ému c'est très flatteur mais je
la dis moi tu sais que je suis venu pour
chanter ma chanson avec casimir et non
pas pour prendre le thé avec toi oui
c'est vrai mais c'est casimir qui après
avoir invité les parties mais juste
avant qu'on arrive et ça c'est bizarre
alors je ne comprends pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé
regarde ton téléphone et décrocher l on
suivrait comme c'est bizarre
non
allons à casimir me
julie elle a
au nom l'eau le téléphone était
débranché où il a raccroché ouais
d'accord d'accord je lui dis ouais ça
lui
s'était faite et casimir il m'a dit
qu'il attendait son jardin près de ton
cul au square en fait ils faire
complètement la tête coiffée du gouffre
courir d'un endroit à l'autre comme ça
vous vivez mais alors s'il ne m'attend
pas gare à lui oui je lis passe par le
sentier des lapins ça mettra de bonne
humeur
merci pour le ter
figurez-vous que taïmyr m'a dit qu'il
arrivait le plus vite possible et que je
lis l'attendent en plus il passe par le
petit bois
c'est drôle je n'ai plus qu'à attendre
la suite des événements
quel spectacle
à cet instant le bouchon de ma ligne
s'enfonce d'un seul coup
excusez-moi facteurs mais j'ai rendez
vous avec julie hamel mutu pourrait y
aller attends attends je pense que
terminer mon histoire beaucoup ont même
ébauché la ligne s'enfonce dire que
j'allais me aubut a enfin pouvoir
m'expliquer ce qui s'est passé mais
enfin mais qu'est ce que tu fais là nous
avions rendez vous chez moi si le
facteur ne m'avait pas retenu je serais
déjà arrivé d'ailleurs j'ai même dit à
léonard au téléphone que je prendrai le
chemin du petit bois pour aller plus
vite
j'ai compris c'est pour ça qu'il m'a dit
de passer par le sentier des lapins
c'est pour que nous nous rencontrions
pas nous courions là après l'autre toute
la journée elle nous a fait bien courir
ça ne m'étonne pas il ne voulait pas que
nous chantions ensemble j'ai tenté
police nous allons
je veux même qu'ils soient témoins tu
vas voir
ça alors
alors allons y en a
et compte attentivement
musique
je voudrais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage être toujours en
bénissant comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on est comme
moi avec des rêves plein la tête
on a des gestes maladroits s'il te plaît
dix mois la recette
en vérité fait plaisir
[Musique]
allier tu veux bien sage sans savoir
tous
c'est ma meilleure
m
[Musique]
arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui
m'emporte
[Musique]
hilary peugeot
gare avec les meilleurs de mes copains
et s'interpose sans crier gare
vérité fait plaisir
c'est gagné que devient seul sens
on
prendra connaissance autour
c'est râpé
[Musique]
je veux bien essayer
pour diminuer mes bêtises se faire
plaisir au monde entier ce sera dur quoi
que tu dis
car en somalie et en secret mathieu du
snop et le acteurs julie mademoiselle
futaie compte aussi parfois des erreurs
très bien savoir comment il peut faire
pour devenir sage d'être toujours obéi
sont comme les enfants sur les images
agen surtout quand on est homme
moi avec des rêves
la tête on a des gestes maladroits mais
j'ai bien compris la rue
[Musique]